for-profit colleges you've probably seen
the commercials hey ladies get it why
can't you get an education for yourself
I chose a latte because it's short you
want to get to the next level ever can
get you there but there's plenty of
evidence to suggest these promises are
lies and the US government has had to
step in to clean up the mess Secretary
of Education Arne Duncan has announced
the government will forgive federal
loans for students who attended
for-profit schools run by Corinthian
Colleges one of the biggest for-profit
chains Corinthian Colleges shut down all
their campuses for good in April and
declared bankruptcy after the government
stopped giving them federal loans which
made up nearly 90 percent of their
revenues the news of loan relief could
mean as many as 350,000 former
Corinthian students could get a total of
3.5 billion dollars back but it's a long
process
so what's up with for-profit education
the schools are run by private
businesses worried about their bottom
lines many are even publicly traded yes
public and private universities are
crazy expensive too but they're not
operating to make investors rich at the
expense of students so what's the appeal
well for profits say they offer quick
degrees and more focused concentrations
but they often prey on people with few
alternatives the government's
investigations of the Corinthian schools
found that WyoTech Everest and Heald
colleges overcharged and deceived
students McKenzie Vasquez attended in
every school and says as a naive 20 year
old who knew little about the education
system the school tricked her they
basically take you in they tell you what
you want to hear they sell you this huge
dream and they profit from it they're
profiting off of people's aspirations
their dreams this is this is just a
money-making business she's not the only
one who fell for that dream enrollment
up for profits has gone up over the
years in 2014 1.4 million students were
enrolled in more than 1300 schools
across the country a number that's
doubled in the last decade even though
that's just about 13% of all students
nationwide for-profit college students
account for 30
percent of loan borrowers and half of
loan defaulters and that's just one way
students are being taken for a ride the
Department of Education find healed
college 30 million dollars in April for
inflating job placement rates some
schools made it look like their job
placement rate was 100 percent when it
totally wasn't on top of that these
schools are known to target the poor
California's Department of Justice
obtained an internal Carinthian document
showing that the colleges target
potential students they call isolated
individuals with low self-esteem who
have few people in their lives who care
about them so this announcement to
forgive loans for people like Vasquez
good news right not in her opinion she
says the government should have stopped
funding these schools years ago when
they began investigating them they know
that they're doing fraud but yet you
want us each individually to go through
and submit these forms that take not a
huge amount of time and then want they
want you to have lawyers well how can I
afford a lawyer if I can't even afford
to pay back my loan you know so this is
boga it's bogus other politicians have
come out against the Department of
Education too like senator Elizabeth
Warren she says it ignored the signs of
mismanagement at these colleges and even
kept them in business so when public
funding for education has gone down and
others are making a profit from it is it
time this country rethinks how it does
higher s
student loan debt in the u.s. is big
business but just how big is big 1.2
trillion dollars